what what does someone do to become  aware awareness hard  right i mean i think the birth of  awareness is asking the question or the  feeling i think there's more to this the  crazy thing about being human maybe it's  true about  being a dog too i don't know but what's  crazy about being human is we tend to  wait till we have to change or we're in  some space where  it hurts so much that we have to listen  you know you start to learn about your  family and then all of a sudden you're  like my childhood was effed you might  have anger towards your parents and i  think one thing that allows us in the  exploration and the excavation of these  things is to see our parents as the  children of parents because then we  start to see that you know they were  handed down the same thing and you know  where do you begin  for me it's always been following the  breadcrumbs i feel like when you ask the  question much like that saying is  when the when the student's ready the  teacher arrives